so when I read about these outbreaks of
bacteria in the newspaper you know in
the cereal industry and the alfalfa
industry tomatoes hamburgers my feeling
of course is the same as as yours it's
dangerous right I don't want to eat that
tomato because I don't have any special
property that makes me better at dealing
with bacteria than you so I have that
reaction the same reaction I think
anyone has when they read about those
except that I think the reaction that I
don't have is the one where people think
everything's getting worse there's all
these pathogens you know that's not true
these pathogens have been on this earth
or these bacteria for billions of years
and the reason we read about them in the
newspaper is not because the bacteria
have changed and gotten worse it's
because technology or industry or the
environment has changed and we're coming
in contact with a bacterium that's just
been hanging around for billions of
years
and then but we're in contact with it
and our immune system doesn't know how
to deal with it and so I think a coli
o157 is a great example of that
it used to be if a farmer's cow you know
ate e : e coli o157 and the cow got
infected and the farmer and his family
ate it it would be unfortunate but it
didn't end up in a thousand hamburgers
you know all over the country you know
that's that's because industry's changed
right and so so these sort of blips that
we see are not because the bacteria are
getting worse and that's the thing I
think that most people don't understand
when they read in the newspaper about
the Salmonella e.coli it's just that in
the technology has changed it's smacked
us up against them right and I'm not
saying we shouldn't fix it we should but
I just wish people would say that
bacteria aren't getting worse and worse
that's not what's happening right he's
just been going on for billions of years
I think that I don't think that I would
never there's a whole editorial on how
we grow b4n things like that right which
is not my expertise at all you know
that's a so each of us makes personal
decisions about the food we want to eat
based on those things but I think that
that you know we're not going to go back
to subsistence farming right I mean it's
gonna be industrialized and so I do
think that there are rather easy
Prevention's of the you know by
monitoring and spending money on
surveillance and monitoring that can can
fix for the most part these problems and
so I think that each time that we have
these unfortunates episodes in fact it
does except for the hysteria that
happens it does actually help us to
strengthen the infrastructure to have
better quality healthy food and there's
certainly a movement you know people
aren't going to tolerate that right and
so I think that all of that works
together and the problem with it is that
the bacteria get the blame you know as
opposed to you know how we humans are
choosing to process food and so that's
the only to me like misconception about
where the blame should land
you